I feel like the campaign's been going on
don't have this feeling that's been
going on for about four years but it
does feel like it's starting to heat up
things are starting to happen
yeah we've narrowed it down to I think
six hundred Democrats Bernie Sanders I'm
glad to see is is is healthy
yeah it's healthy feeling better Bernie
Bernie Sanders yeah Bernie has fully
recovered from his heart attack and this
weekend true story one of his advisors
said imagine Bernie but with 100 percent
blood flow yeah well I just did and now
I'm completely grossed out a hundred
percent blood flow White House acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney is in
trouble for comments he made about
Ukraine yeah well then he said look I'm
just here for a couple of months so I
can go on Dancing with the Stars
that's not listen don't listen to a word
I say
just get me to that TV show this weekend
former presidential candidate Mitt
Romney revealed he has a secret twitter
account under the name Pierre de lecto
well this gets better check this out a
reporter for The Atlantic asked Mitt
Romney which late-night comedians he
follows in Twitter this is true he said
the following what's his name the big
redhead from Boston
it's the only reason I call the show
Conan mix-ups they don't get the show in
Utah no mitts like Conan what a weird
first name
okay MIT anyway I got over that that was
a little bit of a kick in the balls but
I got over it
I went through some of peered elect oohs
tweets I did and in hindsight it's
pretty clear it was Mitt Romney all
along I don't know why we didn't see
this when you read the tweets it's clear
it was always MIT Romney here are some
of the tweets over the last couple of
months from Pierre de lecto there's this
one does anyone else find ketchup to be
too spicy hashtag Taco Tuesday hashtag
virgin marks there's this one the
automated voice that says wait at Street
crossings is too sexy check this one out
apples are too crunchy and bananas are
too mushy but you can't go wrong with a
pear just took the which Harry Potter
character or you personality quiz and it
turns out I'm the wand
[Applause]
there's this one these sexy Halloween
costumes keep getting worse a sheet with
two holes in it pure pornography and
finally I had another sexy dream about
that big rig late night from Boston
what's his name again God he's so
unmemorable
you